لجدل السيطره على الاوضاع او الاوساط عفوا
الصحيه لاعوام حول الاكثر ضررا لصحه
الانسان ايضا دهون
كربوهيدرات لتتحول الى سكريات داخل الجسم
دراسه خلصت هذه الدراسه حديثه خلصت الى ان
اتباع نظام غذائي منخفض الدهون هو الافضل
المشكله انه يعني كل مره بتطلع دراسه
بتنفي الدراسه اللي قبلها واحنا بطلنا
عارفين
ولا عن السعرات النفي على كل حال اذ يمكن
مشاهدينا انه يقلل طبعا هذا الموضوع من
خطر الموت كل عام بنسبه تصل الى 34% فيما
طبعا اتباع حميه قليله الدهون ايضا
المكملات الغذائيه منخفضه او الاكل
المنخفض الكربوهيدرات يؤدي الى زياده خطر
الوفاء ايضا بنسبه تخيل اعاده تصل الى 38%
طيب كما اظهرت هذه الدراسه ان الاشخاص
اللي يعانون او يتبعون نظاما غذائيا شبيها
بحميه الكيتو كانوا اكثر عرضه للوفاه
لنسبه 28% لاي سبب سبب مقارنه باقران هم
من ذوي الكاربو هايدرات العاليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات